Rick Sutcliffe ESPN baseball analyst
former Cubs Indians pitcher Dodgers
pitcher - some will be calling the
National a divisional series between the
Dodgers and the Braves with Chris Berman
starting tomorrow he joins us now
hey son how are you where are you right
now out on the deck looking at the ocean
in San Diego were you that I mean I'm in
Connecticut I'm not staring at the ocean
but good for you good for you
you know I was gonna start off with
apologizing for Monday as you know John
Sean B David Ross and I did the game in
LA against the Rockies and we just got
word that our ratings for that day were
the highest in the 20-year history of
ESPN and I wanna apologize because I
would imagine your ratings were very
good buddy yeah yeah because we were
competing with you son a couple years
ago and when they brought a bunch of the
the old guys back to do play-by-play
yeah remember when Curt Gowdy and a lot
of those guys came back how cool it was
white I mean what why wouldn't it bring
you back now to do again no I mean you
know I never did games I know I know
that was that but I you know they wanted
me to come back for SportsCenter but I
didn't want to come back and do Support
Center you know speaking of old farts
you know I started on the division
series on radio with the remover let me
tell all your listeners out there the
key to driving fast is years ago like in
Chicago when I played there I would keep
like you know baseball's there in case I
got pulled over it was always convenient
but a lot of these cops these days don't
remember this playing so I have like I
have Chris Bryant balls I have any
veterans I have a couple of Bill
Murray's in my car I know I know I can
imagine that looks for my registration
but you missed you buddy bad you came up
with the Dodgers right I did yeah okay
but did you pitch for the Dodgers are
you were just in the organization okay
no I came up in 76 I got called up from
double-a in September I got injured in
77 got back at the end of 78 and then 79
I was there 80 81 I was with the club 81
during that strike season they went on
to win the World Series I wasn't on that
postseason roster I rearranged Lasorda's
office as you remember and I ended up
getting traded to Cleveland about a week
later yeah what was the build-up to that
when you go in and you get so upset we
Tommy the sorted that you just tear
everything apart well I was told that I
was gonna get to start one more game and
the second half of the season it didn't
matter and and Tommy started saying that
the opportunity to present itself one
thing led to another and I just started
rearranging you know his office a little
bit he didn't care for that but a career
really a life saving moment was I was
gonna throw his role in tear through the
big Frank Sinatra wall
you've been at you saw you know all the
pictures and albums all over the world
to Tommy love Frank and as I started to
throw it Dusty Baker had come into the
office and he grabbed the chair and he's
laughing he told me he said kid he said
you're in enough trouble you don't need
Frank pissed off so that's probably the
number one reason I'm able to be with
you here today but if you didn't do that
what would happen what would have
happened with your career if you didn't
go crazy and tear apart Tommy Lasorda's
office do you know that that's a great
question because I went to Cleveland and
ran into a guy named Bert Blyleven and
the first week of camp you said hey come
on go running with me and he used to go
run for like six to eight miles three or
four times a week well I couldn't I
couldn't keep up halfway with him and
Dan seriously the next thing you know at
the end of camp I'm running with it I
mean I'm not faster than him but I'm
running with him
and like a month into the season Dave
Garcia gave me an opportunity to get
into the rotation and as he handed me
the baseball he said don't let anybody
take it away from ya and that was 82 I
was lucky to win the year or a title in
82 I was an all-star in 83 84 of course
you know Chicago was a lot of fun and a
lot of that had to do with what
seriously running into bird Blyleven and
Dave Garcia believing in me let me start
with the baseball last night the Cubs
are out it is the Cubs dynasty over here
oh no no no no no not even close to
being over I will say that I I would
imagine he was going to make some
changes what they are I don't know you
know there were some guys that had off
years there were some free agent
signings that didn't work there were a
lot of things that that that didn't go
well but yet when you look at it I mean
they still won 95 games I think the
biggest thing that I saw that they need
they didn't have was was speed I think
they had 60 stolen bases on the year
Baez had a third of those whose parents
were came over and I mean what of you
know I think he stole a half dozen bases
at the end that made everything look
like hey that's what we need we need
guys in the lineup that can do that but
it was just the inconsistency Dan you
know the story I mean they 40 times they
scored one run or didn't score
you know they 21 times since the
all-star break that happened if they
scored two or more runs since the Austin
since the all-star break they were 37 or
13
it was just inconsistent but I'll tell
you what everybody appoints at 13
innings last night and losing two to one
you go back to Monday they lost three to
one the game that got me we did the game
free Espeon on Friday against st. Louis
they won the game that got me was the
game Saturday they lost two to one the
st. Louis really a team that had nothing
really going for it they knew that there
wasn't a lot for them to play for I
think they might even been eliminate at
that time but then they lost to 2-1 to
st. Louis on Saturday if they
lose that game there's no game 163
there's no wild card game i point back
to that game has really been the thing
that led to all of this and it's
interesting talking to Rick Sutcliffe
Sutton will be on the call with Chris
Berman Dodgers Braves and that will be a
tomorrow the nationally divisional
series surprise Clayton Kershaw is not
going Game one no I'm not it's it's not
Dan it's not the Clayton Kershaw that
that we've known you know Walker Buehler
is Dave Roberts didn't want to say it
the other day but he's become their ace
I mean he by far has the best stuff that
they have you know the postseason
history for for Clayton it's not great
although it's gotten better as of late
and and and you know when when you're
talking about the Dodgers and you're
talking about Andrew Friedman we learned
with him and Joe Maddon down in Tampa
that they're smarter than just about
everybody else in the game videos in
that conversation as well but you know
there's data that they have that we're
just not privy to I've seen it in spring
training a lot with the Cubs information
that but I didn't have to begin with
with the ESPN but I'm sure you know that
there's a lot of analytics and
sabermetrics and all that crap that I
know nothing about I'm sure there's a
lot of that that led to somebody else
starting Game one and Clayton you know
picking up the second game we had Orel
Hershiser on last week and he said he
thinks dog he thinks Clayton Kershaw's
the greatest pitcher of all time well
I'm not gonna argue with that I would
say the greatest I ever saw was was Greg
Maddux and I know that they have a lot
of things in common you know I don't
know if Clayton's going to get to 350
wins but I will tell you a great story a
couple of years ago believe it or not
Sandy Koufax came into the booth and we
were doing a game and I asked him if he
would sit down with us and he sat down
for a full inning and I posed a question
to him Dan I said Clayton Kershaw was
pitching I said is it fair that people
want to compare Clayton Kershaw his
career to your career and he said Rick
he said I just hope when Clayton's
career is done they still want to enter
me into a way and so what he
in that great yeah I mean in that I mean
it's just it's so humble it's always and
he's always been but I think he was
being honest as far as that is concerned
as well and you know if Clayton is able
to continue to pitch through these back
issues his career probably will in a lot
of ways
there probably be better numbers than
what there were with Sandy you know
what's missing though is that World
Series ring what is it about you know
Maddux wasn't a great postseason pitcher
well Glavine wasn't a great postseason
pitcher I don't know if it's just
coincidence
bad luck but what is it about these
great pitchers some some of the all-time
great pitchers who just weren't good in
the postseason no you're exactly right I
think it comes down to the strikeout I
think it comes down to you know the
power pitching you go back and look at
Jon Lester and what he's done you look
at Verlander what he did last year I
think it's come down to that and you
know nowadays I mean if you don't throw
97 I mean you're a finesse guy yeah and
those guys really want power coaches I
think one thing too damn it doesn't get
considered in it and it gives even more
credit to guys like Lester and Smoltz
who have gone on and done great things
you know Maddux and Glavine by then it's
known 250 innings every year you know
you're not going to physically be at
your best so I think some of that led
into some of the things that went on but
you know there's there's a the
postseason is just a different thing you
can go out there in the regular season
give up three in the first inning and
not worry a lot of times you're going to
especially in American League you're
going to pitch six or seven innings but
you do that in the postseason you know
the next thing you know you're you know
there's somebody up in the first inning
to come in and bear you out what kind of
chances do you give the Rockies against
the Brewers I've got the Brewers going
to the World Series Dan I said that a
couple of months ago Craig Counsell has
done an amazing job
the additions they made in the winter
with Cain and yelets they brought them
in on the same day and then the the
versatility that he has with that lineup
Craig was telling us a couple of months
ago where they brought in with stockist
and
they added some depth to that bullpen he
goes I've got some bullets he goes I've
got you know if we've got we're down by
a run in the ninth inning wait till you
see the three guys that I'm able to send
up to hit he also likes the back end of
his bullpen he also likes a lot of the
things that he has there too
to close down a win so a couple of I
mean literally because everybody thought
the Dodgers are the Cubs he's gonna go
to the World Series I think it was about
a month ago when I when I they're not
the best team hmm watch him to walking
and the lineup and what Cain does there
you know all of a sudden Yelich has
become the MVP of course but there's
some link to that lineup and there's
some depth and quality to the back end
of that bullpen have you done any
practical jokes lately hold any pranks
on your celebrity friends I'm sure I
have you know thinking of one really off
the bat I can't but I you know what I go
back to my favorite one of all thank you
I mean we were there for Mark Grace's
first golf tournament and you know they
bring Bill Murray up and worry you you
know he critiques me really good and
then all of a sudden Gracie grabbed the
mic we started auction off that trip to
Randy and his fantastic camp and Gracie
right off the bat bid $1,000 and he said
I to I told my dad right there gene
grace that I was going to buy him a trip
to the fantasy camp and Murray grabbed
the mic and he said mm was back and
forth all sudden Gracie said $10,000 for
a trip to Randy honey's fantasy camp
from my dad and Murray grabs the mic and
only like he can and character he's
almost crying because I told my dad that
I would buy him a trip to randy
Hundley's fantasy camp but my dad died
seven years ago you know we can go for
free any time anyway I thought that was
didn't you use to do stuff to Mark
Harmon all the time the the great actor
do you you guys don't do that anymore
you know mr. Vincey is and all of that
he's just he's kind of hard to get to
you know he's got security around me but
one of my favorite things of all was
when the last week of David Letterman
show you guys can go back and look at it
Mark Harmon was one of the guests of
course that last week and it's been a
talking about NCS harp talked about all
the mean things that I've done to him
but you know he got the you know he
finally got more than even remember when
they put that billboard up on me at
Wrigley right before the all-star game
they not only put my heist my my phone
number on it which that's all we had
yeah for ticket information he also get
over it but then they put my senior high
school picture up on that tag and I I
don't know you know I I don't look good
now but I look back then but the
funniest part was Armand on Letterman he
told David he said yeah here's what
happened you know we bury Axelrod and I
our agent we they cost seventeen
thousand dollars and we called fifteen
people to see if they wanted to get even
with Sutcliffe it'll cost you a thousand
dollars
but didn't you dump like like rocks in
his front yard or something didn't you
do what some of the dump truck with Mark
Harmon he was he was rearranged and he
was redoing his house which you know he
loves to do a lot of that stuff and he
went into this big storage bin where
they had all the utilities and stoves
and thanks to show Jennifer Axelrod
Barry's wife this stove is mom is lefty
anyway his Jennifer came out I locked
mark into that storage locks and anyways
we're on our way to the ballpark I was I
was playing for the Cubs that day Berry
says well I wonder where Mark said he
didn't answer his phone and Sue well I
know is that he's like you left him in
there yeah they eventually came to get
him out but yeah that was it
you know and and the favorite thing was
his bachelor party when he brought all
of his celebrity friends to Arizona you
know he's the sexiest man alive on
People magazine and you know when they
get out I've got RINO and Jody and Zonk
there we're going to have a game we're
gonna play a game against
Hollywood stars and I give them t-shirts
and hats and wristbands and his banners
are running out the center-field I was
going to hit him some fly balls to get
him loose mark looked to our agent
Axelrod and said this is awesome he goes
what a great guy Rick is and Dan right
as I got him all the center-field I had
the ground crew like a BB gun they're
all laying on the ground and they had to
crawl off and you know it was recycled
sewer water and of course I took all
their luggage to get it that so they end
up you know wearing those Cubs t-shirts
the rest of the night so yeah that's why
the yeah I can understand that more of
sout telling stories with chris berman
that'll be tomorrow Dodgers Braves whose
win in this series the Dodgers a win
this one okay I got the Dodgers over
Atlanta Milwaukee I think will beat the
ranked Milwaukee Oh beat the Dodgers to
go to the World Series and I've got
Cleveland I've got Cleveland waiting on
him when this thing's all said that good
to catch up never been right though you
tell great stories though tell-tell
boomer we settle oh and good to catch up
with you son we'll do it the toys a
pleasure down thank you buddy thank you
buddy that's Rick Sutcliffe ESPN
baseball analyst former Cubs Indians
Dodgers pitcher for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]